cki marraine doyer anniversaire ma puce
madame north
toutes mes condoléances ces cartels ne
plaisante pas
ils ont tout le monde dans la poche
solaire connaît les preuves ne sont pas
suffisantes pour traduire les accusés
êtes persuadé que justice vous sera
rendu que vous lui ferez tous payés
il ya cinq ans rails les noces a disparu
de la circulation aujourd'hui ça fait
cinq ans que sa famille a été assassinée
[Musique]
de retour le juge corrompu ific pourri
ce que je vais
justice soit rendue
trouver là j'en ai rien à [ __ ] même si
vous devez brûler la ville entière pour
ça lorsqu'on vous enlève ce qui compte à
mes yeux
votre vie mais une autre personne on est
organisé comme et armés vous croyez que
ça va finir comment
je vais tous vous tuer et après ça eh
bien je proposerai